that's right I'm standing in Yankee
Stadium and it's raining a lot of you
were thinking ha ha Conan you can't play
baseball the hell I can't
I can pray computer baseball on a
computer you didn't think of that did
you not only that I can play with one of
the game's biggest stars
I am very exciting so I'm sitting here
with one of the biggest stars in
baseball mr. Aaron judge mr. judge yeah
yeah I hear you're quite the game all
right I came a little bit came a little
bit you were on the cover of the show 18
you're on the cover of this game that's
a big deal I've only been on the cover
of one video game which video game oh
you didn't heard about it
it's Conan's extreme lawn mowing
adventure I have the second one you at
the center that is good you have an
amazing amazing ability to hit the
baseball and you have an incredible
stance an incredible eye I would curious
if you could just maybe rate my stance
could you take a look at it I'd love to
yeah I like my ass out I like this way
out almost pointed towards the pitcher
and then I like just sort of let this
thing hang right
and then what I like to do is I'd like
to step out over the plate and then
swing down this way
what are you thinking about what I'm
doing it's not good before you get into
the boxes are like a little pre routine
you do or is it Oh way to get inside the
pitchers head okay so a lot of times I
like to skip up to the plate
that gets from thinking like who is this
guy what does he know that I don't know
you know when I'm in the on-deck circle
I like to do a lot of rubbing of myself
I think that would get into the pitchers
head as well did it's get into my head
what's that that's good into my head you
don't do in a good way or and again not
not in a great way I'm not sure yet
I'd also if I was a batter I'd stand
around the bat behind my head like this
a lot
and I would just pose sort of like this
is that even a real bet is it well it's
funny you bring that up I'm very excited
to play this game is it weird you ever
play as yourself I don't I feel like
that's just a little too weird I don't
get that because when I play these games
I can't play as Conan O'Brien and what I
really want to do is play as a very
pretty girl
they don't allow that Aaron this is
Aaron we're gonna play this game what
can you tell us about it yeah I don't
know much MLB the show 18 Aaron judge
cover athlete and you know the origins
of modern baseball can be tricked out
you're shouting you shove it sorry and
we don't have to know about the origins
of the baseball we all know what was
invented in France in the late 1950s why
do we start with a homerun Derby with
you guys against each other I think I'm
gonna go with Giancarlo Stan hey Ted
Williams I'll be back okay great
go get him not a lot of fun to hang
around with
[Laughter]
yeah so this is Yuka me first you're up
first
okay all right so you have two minutes
all right here we go whoa check it out
right oh yeah oh my god I never knew
playing baseball was this easy I'm a
great athlete and I okay I love saying
that and then missing completely fast
I am so odd
not only by your talent but what you've
done is a player here in the Yankee so
quickly you've got this amazing fan base
oh yeah I get to play it from the best
fans in the world every night so it's
pretty amazing and this whole thing the
judge's chambers that's fantastic they
just sit in a special section and they
dress like judges judge shows huge would
you be open for trying it very quickly
right now we have two roommates that
have a dispute you can decide it's time
now for judge judge okay the plaintiff
John Drucker claims his roommates build
a glass of wine on his white shag carpet
he wants to be compensated for the rug
and emotional distress the defendant has
a defendant and he what kind of
squirrely his roommate Matt Thompson he
says the rug was already dirty judge
judge you've heard their cases do you
find for the plaintiff the guy who
spilled the wine or for the defendant
the roommate who says the rug was
already dirty
like the the rugs already dirty ins
sorry dirty I think judge judge fines
for the defendant all you have to do is
hit your gavel and say you've been
judged
you've been judged so you're gonna start
you're gonna pitch Aaron you're gonna
pitch to Conan and you know you just hit
the buttons of that it says when you go
away please you're humiliating yourself
and the sport it's baseball legs are you
make me look like a douchebag
okay I think I just killed a fan I just
killed a fan the police are on their way
what's happening now is this you now
hitting yeah okay and I'm gonna give you
a slider good luck to you right just eat
your pie over and over gamma look at
that I'm sorry I know this is really
childish but I think it's funny that
you're trying to hit the ball and I'm
just what the Oh what am I supposed to
do is I supposed to catch that
whoa if you suck look my guy has had a
nervous breakdown okay oh here comes oh
so now you're playing as yourself I'm
trying to run why isn't it running
[Applause]
you've been judged
horrifies Erin judge an incredibly
amazing talent
you